[Music]
national titles are on the line as
America's best congregate in St Louis
America's chess Capital to compete in
the US and US Women's Chess Championship
for the 15th consecutive year beginning
Thursday October 5th 24 players across
both Fields will VI for over $400,000 in
prizes Fabiano Carana and Jennifer Yu
look to defend their titles and add to
their Championship crowns you don't want
to miss the US and US Women's Chess
Championship brought to you by the St
Louis chess club join us for the opening
ceremony of the US chess championships
and US Chess Hall of Fame inductions at
city park on October 4th in the closing
ceremony at Chase Park Plaza on October
18th for more information and to
purchase tickets visit us chess
champs.com
catch all the action on the St Louis
chess club YouTube and twitch Channel
El